now with the trip that's kind of give
gone global that sold all over the world
yeah well where it's just a TV series
here but around the world
it's it's a film and you must know when
you go home you must look up on YouTube
think because they dub it into other
languages okay so if you can see it in
in Spanish so I was keen to see this I
thought what sort of voice have they
given me and it starts off with Steve
right and he's driving the car and I'm
next him they've given him a very sexy
Spanish voice so he's driving when
quantal a mystery Cola by Otto on Tobiah
then I'm just sat there like this when a
restaurant I'm still not speaking just
him yesterday about the video earlier
I still say nothing diggin what is my
voice going to be then we get back in
the car again it's him
Elizabeth we do look cool silver and I
go
47 sexiest man in way
but when War injuries me when they dub
it into the different languages I don't
know if you watched enough to get this
but when they do the impressions what
are they doing impressions of are they
doing impressions of the people who
dubbed them in those countries all right
so that's an interesting point
Arlis party riccati a lot is surely a
rowdy depart me Amano Michael kite
[Applause]
[Music]
you